Hello, everybody. My name is Markiplier and welcome back to Crash Bandicoot.
I'm still going, I didn't even take a break.
I didn't even take a breather.
I didn't need one.
Remember how cool and calm and collected I am?
That's how I'm gonna go into this next few set of levels.
So I I know, I know, you guys are all like,  "Hey, this Markiplier guy seems out of his goddamn mind."
You're right about that.  I'm out of my gourd, but that's okay.
Cuz I'm back in the seat, and we don't have to do a God damn- well that was...
I gotta stop rushing into things and I gotta start-
Going forward with my feelings.
No. Again, I was just about to go forward without my feelies.
Gotta have my feelies in my bag before I go ready and jump off a ledge. Oh, frick. Okay.
That's a nice jump. Oh, that's a faith jump.
What are you- what is wrong with you old man, are you okay? What are you feeling for- ah. Okay. I guess we're going now.
Uh. You know what I'm not gonna do.
No, this was bad timing okay, but it worked out for me. I'm gonna jump on you.
I worked!! It worked that bird died and saved me!!
Worthy sacrifice hey, I'm- oh- DUUCK
Why didn't I wait till I got to the bottom before I tried to jump in the hole? I don't know
I'm just so eager to get in that hole.
Guh. Alright. Carrying on as if nothing happened.
So, you want to run that by me again? Oh, I hate getting these boxes over and over again
I don't even care about the completion. That's bullshit, but I got to do it in my brain
SomeBODY once told me the world was gonna roll me-okay
Don't- j-just stop grabbing me, you freaking weirdo. Ah
I almost didn't make that. That would have been cool,
if I didn't make that. Right? Remember? Remember how fun and happy it is whenever I fail, and everyone's like "Hahahahaha he's
mad!" Ah.
Yeah, you remember that? The good old days? Kay, wait till I get to the bottom and then go in the hole?
(Screaming hysterically.) NOT HIGH ENOUGH!!!
I wasn't high enough. It wasn't high enough. Guys, guys.
Did you know? Did you know it wasn't high enough? Guys, did you hear the news? Have you heard the good word?
It wasn't high enough to be able to get in there. Ha ha ha. I wasn't high enough for this game. Not high enough-
Oh fricking. Why why why you- OOOHHH!
I thought you were done. Why's your hand so goddamn lethal?
Why? All right, you know what? I'm just gonna fuck oh.
I guess this is game over
So why can't we do it again?
Because of the do dat, because there's a strategy then I can get more game like the game lives
I'm barely in the beginning of goddamn level and I can't get through it. What's wrong with me? I'm a better gamer than this
Here all you laughing. Don't do that. I did it. Again Again AGAIN!! I did it again again.
Oh, I don't wanna do this. Oh, no. I want to play the game. I don't want to be bad
That's what I don't want to do. No, stop. Again, like I don't know what it is about me. That's just like, "Go!!"
"Go, right, it'll all work out in the end.
What you- you don't need to wait, why wait? Take it!! Take your chance. Thank your one opportunity.
Remember, if you only add one chance. One opportunity,
would you take it?" Don't miss your chance to blow is what I'm saying. Just, if you got an opportunity to blow.
Like he said you gotta blow! Her mom's spaghetti remember? Remember mom's spaghetti t-shirt? Spaghetti already? Mom's spaghetti.
You're nervous.
Are you talking to yourself? Yeah, I think I am, actually. Oh, great.
That's what I've been doing in all my let's plays. People think I'm talking to the camera, nah.
Just talking to myself. It's not worth it. I'm not gonna go forward- that would been the bad timing anyway, so.
Great. Am I just on the wrong circuit? I'm on the wrong one, aren't I? Okay, wait. No I think if
I wait a little longer. I think if I wait- yeah yeah, yeah. You did it! Yeah, yeah yeah, yeah, yeah! Oh it's turtles all over again.
Turtles in time. Oh, go faster, okay?
Great. Oh these bastards. Have I even hit a checkpoint yet?
I don't think I have. Why are there so many identical twins in here?
Where's my goddamn checkpoint? If you don't give me a goddamn checkpoint soon- have I hit one? I don't even remember.
I could have blacked out... and
You know I wouldn't have been able to I-I
I have no idea where I- who am I? Who am I? Okay. Oh, this looks bad.
I don't like that. Heee dooo
Got the timing though. Got the timing though. You better gimme a- if you don't give me a goddamn
checkpoint. I swear I'm gonna kill everyone- NO!!!
Why am I down here now?
No. Oh no. Oh, no, I have to- oh no.
Okay. I don't like that.
Okay, oh, we made it. Still no checkpoint. Don't know why. Don't know why no checkpoint?
Go no, oh no. Oh, no. That's not right. Please tell me a bird's gonna come back. Oh
Convenient. Boink. Yes, okay. I don't- I don't want that.
No!! No, no no no no NOO!!!
Oh no! Why no checkpoint? Why?
Why would you do that to a human being?
Why would you do that? Oh.
That's so cruel. Oh my God. Oh my God. OOOOOOHHHH!
I was thinking about the quick ones up ahead. Oh my god. Oh my God.
How can they do this to a human?
How can they do this to a person?
NOO! I- GAAAAH!!!
Hey, you're brighter now. I can see your face. Boink. Okay, so far so good
Okay
No, God dammit. It's so close. It's so close. How do you do that?
Okay, I made it. I don't know how but I made it. Okay, still no checkpoint. Great. Made it though.
(Exasperation)
Why is there no Checkpoint? Crime against humanity.
Crime crime
Crime Crime crime
That's not a checkpoint. That's an app-
Please let me have that. Don't do anything dickishly before I get there.
Please don't. I'm begging you, I can smell the dickitry.
Okay.
Ah.
I cannot believe that is the checkpoint. I cannot believe!
Okay, but everything's fine, because I'm cool, calm and collected. Most importantly of all I'm
collected.  I feel good about life. I feel good about life. I'm lying
I'm lying. Lies lies. I feel good. I'm lying. That's not right the timing is off.
It's *distorted* off. The timing is *even more diatorted* off. Af.
The timing is af. Ah. Oh, yes. I like bags of dicks. I like bags of them.
I like bag dicks. Ag dicks are my favourite
What just splooshed over there? Ooh.
Why? Sir? Why Sir? Sir? Why? You don't have an infinite supply.
That's not how science and/or physics works. Oh
I thought maybe
Okay, you wiggly wobbly bastards
Uzuki. Okay. Doing great. I'm in the flow of it.
I think. I feel good. Again, lies lies lies. Again lies I tell lies to make myself feel better.
Make myself feel better. I'm just doing a warm-up guys, I don't know what you're talking about. Vocal warm-ups and all that.
Okay. Oh boy, it's me again somehow I made it all the way up here. I'm really moving up in life.
Uh oh.
No!! GAH-I love!!!
That was the easy- why do I die there? Why there? I-I
panic. I have a freaking extra shield on me, and I panic.
Why the
Fuck. Losing it. I'm losing it. I was so calm.
I was so in the Zone
and then I lose it on the old guys just flailing like a bunch of- not again. Not again
Not again, not again, not again. Not this time not ever. Not ever again. Never again. Aright you old piece of this shit
I don't have an extra hit for this so don't
Fucking hit me.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, I don't understand that but okay. I thought I was dead for sure but all right.
- okay.
Hey, what the hell is this bonus area? I've never been here before. Let's find- let's go on an adventure.
What is this? I don't like this. I don't like this.
I'm just going oh, oh
Wohahahahahahaho.
Well, well, well, well, well (repeated handful more times).  Well at least I get to do this one again. That's great. Okay, cool. All right, cool.
Oh, yes, please
I'm not crazy right?  the difficulty
ramped up a lot. What the f is wrong with me
Why can't I make that? Why am I not making that jump?
Why am I not making that? There's no excuse for this. There's a freaking bonus round. I should be bad
ah
Again, why?
What's going on? What the hell is happening?
There we go. There we go. No, my bonuses. No my bob-my bonuses! ah
My bonuses. It's fine. Didn't need it. Ah.
That's a lot of lives. Actually, you just blew up.
I don't know why you blew up. Thank you for the lives nonetheless.
I ain't gonna ask you many questions about that. All right carrying on.
I think that acts as a checkpoint, so I think I'm uuh l saved.
No, wrong!!! Come back to me. Why would you do that?
Are you going-where you going buddy? I'm not going for that.
Oh, I should. I should but I'm not. I got lives in the bonus round, so I guess I'm gonna be fine.
Me no, how, I (scream)
I let go, I didn't think I was gonna hit it. I thought let go.
Oh, man! Ah you're such a tease!! You're such a tease. You're such a tease.
No, this was wrong, but I guess we're fi- (sigh) Oh!
Don't let me die to him. Don't let me die to him. Do not-
Even they know, that this level was ducked.
(low growl)
oh
I don't even feel like overjoyed when I beat it finally. The the ending is such an anticlimactic piece of Garbo.
Oh man, I'm never gonna finish this game if this was gonna take. If this is how there's gonna go the whole time.
If this is how it's gonna go,
then I'm never gonna beat this game.
Thank you everybody so much for watching. Hope you've been enjoying it,
I'm gonna keep going. I am. I really am. Oh, this better Be like the last island. I don't even know if it is.
It could be, it could be, it could not be.
Whatever. So either way, thank you everybody so much for watching. Let me know how I'm doing in the comments below.
I know, terribly or amazingly. Perseverance is everything right?
So thanks again, and as always I will see you in the next video. BUH BYE!!!